ん
皆さん想像してみてください
今あなたは
東北の被災地の
小高い丘の上に立っています
眼下には雄大な三陸の海が広がっています
海面は木の光を受けてキラキラと輝いています
小鳥のさえずりが聞こえてきます
温かく優しいそよ風か
あなたのほほうなでます
足元には
いちめんのなのはな畑が広がっています
今菜の花の代わりがしませんでしたか
私はこの光景を実現することが夢です
私のこの活動が
東北につながるとは
はじめは思ってもいませんでした
きっかけは
私の家の目の前にある九大六本松キャンパスが
は私が小学校6年生の時に移転したことにした
町からは九大生の姿が消え
一気に寂しくなりました
私は中学1年生になりなんとかしてこの大好きな六本松の街を元気にしたいと思うよう
になりました
そして思いついたのが
菜の花で私の大好きな菜の花でこの街を彩ることでした
初めは
たくさん大変なこともありました
お金もないし育て方も知らないし
土地も行政から借りなければいけません
種まきも一人で周囲には大変です
そんな中でねー
国土交通省から土地を借り
無事1年目綺麗に花を咲かせることができました
このカラーの周りに
お年寄りの方が座って談笑している姿を見たとき
横断歩道を待つ人が菜の花を写真にとっているのを見たとき
私は
とても嬉しかったです
普段は通り過ぎる人たちが
その場で足を止めて
時間と空間を共有している
幸せがつながるそんな瞬間を目にした時
ああやってよかったなぁと
思いました
年目私は
1年目に断られていた境内や土地ないを貸していただけることになりました
九大生の方々や ur の職員の方々
地域の方々に種まきを手伝ってもらいながら
2200平方メートルの土地に菜の花や菜の花の種を蒔きました
ちゃる
見事に咲きました
ちょうどこのころ
経済や土地の工事も一段落し
地域のお祭りが開かれました
私はこの菜の花を咲かせることでお祭りを盛り上げることができました
ちょうどこのお祭りに
きていらっしゃった記者の方にお会いでき
新聞に載せていただいたり
この活動を書いた作文が
表彰されたり
国際ボランティア団体に
表彰されたりしました
そして今やっているのがおいっちに運動という活動です
おいっちに遠藤とは
01にと書きます
何もやらない白ではなく何かやる
1を選ぼうという活動です
タネを私たちの事務局から希望された方に送りそのタネを汁自宅で育ててもらってその
大事に育った
育ててもらって花が咲いたときその人も楽しんでもらえるんですよね
でそれの
それが枯れた後の種を畑収穫してその人たちの思いのこもった種をまたは遠くに御苦労
っていう活動です
この想いがつながる活動を
活動をしているとき
参加者からこういう手紙をたくさんいただきました
思いがつながるという感動を体感しました
でも私は満足していません
なぜだと思いますか
それは
まだ何も東北のために
何も活動できていないからです
私が行っている活動は偽善ではないのか
ただの自己満足ではないのか
そう思ったことが何度もありました
皆さんは何か東北のために活動されたことがありますか
今実際に行っている方いらっしゃる方も
いるかもしれませんし芯材があった後すぐ
現地に赴かれた方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
でも私は
やりたいという思いはあるんですがまだ実際に東北に行ったこともありませんし
以前球団跡地で育ったあの菜の花の種を東北に送ったことがあるんですがそれも残念
ながら
芽が出なかったそうです
そして今私は
協力者を協力していただいている方の土地を借りて
広大な土地に
他にお前巻いていますもうすぐ
目がもうちょっと大きくなって作じゃないかなって楽しみにしてます
そして将来私は
現地に咲かせた
菜の花を
小さくても想いをつなげる産業にしたいという夢があります
私が植えた菜の花を
菜の花から黄色い色素をとって
例えばハンカチを染めたりしてそれを
例えば高速道路のパーキングエリアで福岡から東北までのパー高速道路のパーキング
営利で打ってもらう
そして
そこで a
集まった資金を東北人をクルー
そういうソーシャルビジネスに
このボランティア活動を支えていきたいなと今思っています
皆さんの体の中を温かい血がながら巡るように
菜の花のあのキー俺染めた製品が
購入者や支援者の思いを乗せて地球中を駆け巡れば
それが私の意味です
人がつながって思いがつながり幸せがつながる
本当普通はそういう順番ではないかと思いますよね
しかし幸せがつながり思いがつながり
人がつながる私はそういう体験をしました
つながることで生まれる幸せもあります
しかし私は小さな幸せを感じている人が
それをほんの少し伝えられる仕組みを
東北と世界をつなぐソーシャルビジネスとして実現したいと思っています
あゆちゃん in english
ああいう大ハンカチーフったイエローキャノーラ坊さん
& ai san d ハ parents rides totes 大 the
movie fan 不幸カー2東北
大会が大ハンカチディファイ oa バランスウォン
キャビン会にスプーンざーサポーターズ者歳かーわームーラーバランスはターボディ
t 氏の親父リアスファイナンシャルさぽーつ
パーティー t 先術 prova は派
5 users ユース王座すぷろふぃーつぷ論議 social business
for 東北
プリー時今人員フォントビューアネックス店 cpu 同部キャノーラ風呂サンズ
i m sure the 1プリングハピネスっ
ユーザー
ハピネスっ
5分東北ば闘争泡大叔母だわー
dc ずマイピクチャーを
ピース茶いるフーディ
io ベイズザブザキャノーラ墓参論ちゃいデー
i want to change my project インター social
business for 東北
ざーてぃ相撲乳汁イン
研究4